[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing effect back in 1989
20 years ago Anissa Ayala of Los Angeles
was diagnosed with chronic myelogenous
leukemia a bone-marrow transplant was
her only hope to survive but neither she
or her parents or her younger brother
had the bone marrow that matched hers
even a massive campaign to recruit new
donors on a national registry produced
no matches for Anissa that's when her
parents aged 44 and 42 decided to have
another baby to save her life even
though they knew the chances of the new
baby being a match for only one in for
Marian aids saw this as their only
option to save their daughter Abe had a
vasectomy reversal and incredibly Mary
got pregnant at age 42 their prayers
were answered and new baby Marissa
turned out to be a perfect match at age
14 months she donated her Morrow to big
sister Aneesa without of course having
much say in the matter
the treatment worked perfectly and today
20 years later Aneesa enjoys perfect
health and is very close to her younger
sister you know friends this is not the
first time that a baby was born
specifically to be a savior stay with us
we're gonna learn more on this edition
of Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 your Holy
Spirit to come and got our hearts our
minds Lord we know that this is a sacred
book and we need your guide so do those
or listening and bless us here in the
studio in Jesus name Amen amen
pastor day you open the program by
talking about well a special birth that
was predetermined or planned to save
somebody else's life
that's incredible story you can imagine
that close those sisters must be today
as you mentioned especially the one that
received life from her youngest sister
and you know it's remarkable it warms
our heart when we see such commitment
and just the devotion and love amongst
the family amongst siblings yeah it is a
it's a very touching story and it's
remarkable how close they the two
sisters are even though they're you know
like 16 years apart
Marissa teases her older sisters saying
you know I could always play the Savior
and say look you got to do this for
exactly I saved your life but she says
she doesn't do that and so they they and
then her older sister said well you want
to be alive if I hadn't gotten sick so
they they have fun making light of it
but it makes us think of something that
is very real in the Bible the Bible
tells us that God sent his son into the
world for the purpose of being a savior
now little Marissa was able to donate
some bone marrow and live but for Jesus
to save us he needed to die and so he
was born to die to save us but praise
the Lord he rose again
first Timothy 1:15 this is a faithful
saying and worthy of all acceptance that
Christ Jesus came into the world to save
sinners
Paul says of Who I am chief and the
angel said to Mary you will call his
name Jesus for he will save his people
not from leukemia but from sin and we
have a free offer that we'd like to make
available to you if you'd like to know
more about that incredible redemption
that story of salvation you will be
encouraged and inspired by reading this
we have a book called the high cost of
the cross and that will make available
to anyone who calls an ass it's free
just a great resource something you can
read it's a lot of scripture in there
talking about the great plan of
redemption it's called the high cost of
the Cross the phone number is 883 five
six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line and if you have a
Bible question the phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven again that's 800 four six
372 97 you're gonna go to the phone
lines we got Lou listening in Sacramento
Lou welcome to the program hello pastor
bachelor and pastor rod sorry hello I'm
calling because my understanding is that
according to the Bible there is only one
definition of sin which is first John
three four and were supported by Romans
3:20 and it's based on my experience I
noticed that many people don't know what
se means according to the Bible yeah let
me read this for our friends first John
three four it says whoever commits sin
commits lawlessness or transgresses the
law for sin is the transgression of the
law and so when we sin we break the law
now there there are some other
definitions of sin just to be fair the
Bible also says all unrighteousness is
sin and then anything that is not of
faith is sin but the best most concise
definition is when we break God's law it
is a sin to steal is a sin to lie is a
sin to commit adultery or kill is a sin
and so yeah some people they don't
understand that it's not that
complicated what sin is and I understand
and I'm thinking that the Word of God is
if the Bible is God's Word and he knows
exactly how shall I said the truth he
knows the truth and the Bible is present
- that is the truth and his voice can be
heard in that sacred book so when he
says that sin is the transgression of it
of the law he means that a lot believe
that it's Bree referring to Exodus 20
and do the romani fie and also I'd like
to mention and secondly is that in
closing but I think that many people
today since we're living pretty close to
the end of time need aid of what is it
resurrection power in their hearts and
to the scripture introduction first thus
saith the Lord and I quote for he say
wherefore he saith a way caught bound
that sleepest and arise from the dead
and Christ shall give the light which is
a spiritual awakening and I praise the
Lord for those beautiful pictures
alright well hey we appreciate that
thank you so much Lou and yeah it is
true people need to rediscover the the
power of God's word and receive the
conviction that comes from it you know
whatever book it's goes along with the
subject it's called is it possible to
live without sinning yeah of course as a
Christian that's the goal that's what
you want to do we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and ask the
number is 883 five seven four seven and
again just ask for the book cold is that
so we'll deliver that sending actually
it's an encouraging book and I think
you'll enjoy it we have Chris is listing
in Florida Chris welcome to the program
thank you Buster's I have a question
about again a returning subject of
clipping said Sabbath and I would like
to go to Isaiah and the book of Isaiah
58 verses 1517 through 14 alright you
want me to read that for people yes
please if you turn away your foot from
the Sabbath from doing your pleasure on
my holy day and call the Sabbath a
delight wholly of the Lord and
honourable and will honor him not doing
your own ways or finding your own
pleasure or speaking your own words then
you will delight yourself in the Lord
and I'll cause you to ride upon the high
places of the earth and feed you with
the heritage of Jacob your father for
the mouth of the Lord has spoken so what
is your question on that verse my
question is that for those who keep this
Sabbath
don't you think they should keep as
close to the restrictions here as
possible of course yeah of course we
should follow what the Word of God says
Bible talks about keeping the Sabbath
holy that not only here in Isaiah it's
telling us that in the commandment
itself both in Deuteronomy 5 that
someone cited a moment ago as well as in
Exodus 20 and everywhere else yeah you
know people do ask about the Sabbath and
is it relevant for Christians today we
do have a study guide that talks about
it's called the last day of history and
this of course is free to anyone who
calls an ass the number is 883 five six
seven four seven and again you can ask
for the study guide it's simply called
the last day in history I think if
you're called Chris we have Doug
listening in Long Beach California Doug
welcome to the program i pastors hi um
like my question has to deal with uh
forgiveness and trust not in a marriage
setting but more about like siblings and
other relatives now do you have to truly
in order to truly forgive do you have to
truly trust to the DES where I'm having
a problem with no well there's no
there's you can forgive a person and
know that they've got a weak
this and you don't want to you don't
want to attempt them or put them in a
position where you're setting them up to
fall I can you know there can be someone
who could offend me or take advantage of
me and I can choose to forgive them but
doesn't mean that they're a trustworthy
person because I forgive them you do not
have to I can forget people and decide
I'm never going to do business with them
again because I don't trust them but I
can forgive them I don't know that
you're required to forgive and continue
to trust people if they're untrustworthy
because some people are just
untrustworthy does that make sense okay
yeah I have an issue with what we're
trusting it's like is being taking that
advantage and I just needed to clarify
that part yeah of course you should
forgive people and you know you even
want to love your enemies but doesn't
mean you need to seek out your enemies
and hang out with them or do business
with them or trust them if they're
untrustworthy mm-hm
thanks to a cold ugh well next quarter
that we have is chaste listening in
Illinois chase welcome to the program
hi you know I'm this is my first time
being on here
I tried to call before but I didn't I
didn't do it right but my question I
have for you all today it's I try to
keep it a little short it could you
explain the process of justification
sanctification and glorification
regarding baptism yeah well I'll take a
start at it first of all for our friends
listening salvations kind of broke up
into three areas justification we come
to the Lord just like we are and like
the thief on the cross we accept the
forgiveness of Jesus for all our past
sins and he declares us forgiven not
based on future promises or behavior but
just by faith sanctification is then
after you've accepted Jesus you continue
following him and you learn to be holy a
saint and it's a new way of living
glorification is when we're alternately
safe from the presence of sin when
you're in glory in heaven and you know
as Jesus was resurrected and he was
glorified with his glorified body the
holy eternal body where no one it really
goes in to glorification from baptism
but when you're baptized you're
justified
by faith but we're even before baptism
you should be experiencing some
sanctification when you're baptizing
you're learning to follow the Lord in
sanctification it's kind of like the
children of Israel are a great example
they were saved by faith in the Passover
lamb they began their journey out of
Egypt right after the Passover lamb
they then crossed the Red Sea so after
they were saved by faith in the lamb
that's justification they hadn't done
any good works or deserved it they went
through the Red Sea they didn't even
have faith to go through the Red Sea
until it parted first and then they get
to Mount Sinai and in the wilderness
they're learning to live a holy life
there lots of ups and downs and that was
the sanctification process when they
cross into the Holy Land
that's a glorification and when we go
into the Promised Land heaven that's a
glorification yeah you know I heard a
one-way pass today it's justification is
being defined as freedom from the
penalty of sin the wages of sin is death
sanctification is being defined as
freedom from the power of sin the Holy
Spirit works within us and glorification
has been defined as freedom from the
presence of sin so from the penalty the
power and the presence perfect does that
help a little bit chase you know that
that definitely helps a lot thank you
very much all right hey thanks so much
you know we do have a gift book we'll
send you a free copy it's called
justification assurance justification
made simple yeah that would be a great
gift and it's free all you need to do is
call 883 five six seven four seven and
again just asked for the book called
justification no eight it's called
assurance justification made simple it's
one of our newer books again eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven as for the book assurance
justification made simple and if you
have a Bible question a phone line is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven we've got Dan listening in
Cleveland Ohio Dan welcome to the
program yeah hello I have a question
that I've wondered about in terms of
Revelation 12 verse 7 and there was a
war in heaven Michael and his angels
waging war with the dragon the dragon
and his angels way
or my question is if if there were
angels that rebelled against God and
they were in heaven how can that be if
Heaven is supposed to be a place of
perfect satisfaction for everything and
everyone that's what makes this verse so
startling is it's telling us that even
in the perfect presence of God in the
capital of the universe wherever that is
that there was a rebellion that broke
out that was so severe of course it's
it's dribble into our world and it is
shocking but the Bible says it so you
know you're asking the question like if
there were angels it's pretty clear
there were because it tells us that the
devil and his angels were cast out the
devil and up to one third of the Angels
it seems to say they joined Lucifer in
this rebellion okay I could understand I
understand that because the Bible
mentions it but I'm pondering that how
can the Angels obviously if they
rebelled they were unhappy about
something or unsatisfied
how could anyone or anything be
unsatisfied if you were in heaven and
would that possibly mean that if we
eventually go to heaven we would find
something that were unsatisfied with not
obviously not rebelled but to maybe you
know how you would complain I guess well
I'll do my best to answer but let me
answer your question with a question
what reason did Adam and Eve have to be
unhappy in the Garden of Eden wasn't it
paradise but it was about heaven heaven
to me is the ultimate ultimate place
that anyone can exist heaven was
paradise also a matter of fact it uses
that word everything God made in the
garden meeting it says it was good good
very good he declared it wonderful and
yet in spite of having no earthly
dissatisfaction the devil planted
dissatisfaction in the mind
Eve you're not you don't have all the
power God has if you eat this fruit
you'll be like God that's the exact same
thing the devil did with the Angels he
said you know we can't create we can't
do everything God can do it's not fair
and he was able to sow seeds of
dissatisfaction and rebellion until it
broke out in the war and you the Bible
is only telling this as much as we can
understand about this I'm sure that
there's a lot more complex issues
happening in the realm of God and angels
certainly and I guess the premise of my
question is then obviously this occurred
but and I'm speculating obviously but is
it possible that week we could end up in
heaven and still be longing for
something or would we have complete
fulfillment and satisfaction once we're
there I think we're going to have
perfect satisfaction the Bible tells us
sin will not rise up a second time in
the book of Nahum chapter 1 and we're
going to know all of the accusations all
of the charges that the devil leveled
against God have been proven false and
so I don't think that argument will work
any more in eternity mm-hmm you know
some of the items that we talking about
here some of the verses actually are
mentioned and expanded upon in our study
guide called did God create a devil I'd
be perfect and I think that's deals with
the very question you're asking if God
is perfect and he created a perfect
angel witted son come from we'll send
that out to you dan or anyone who calls
and ask it's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and after the
study guide called did God create a
devil journey back through time to the
center of the universe
discover how a perfect angel transformed
into Satan the arch-villain the birth of
evil a rebellion in heaven
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love than
what went wrong
we've got Chris listening in Nebraska
Chris welcome to the program huh how you
guys done good thank you for calling
thank you I wanted to ask what type of
Scrolls or Bible was Jesus using in the
synagogue's
and how many different Bibles would
there be from that point up until like
the Reformation in the 1300s well we
need to see how many different kinds of
Bibles the the books that Jesus would
have been reading from there is no new
Testament Jesus was reading from the the
Torah he was reading from the law when
he stood up and he read from Isaiah for
example it's the same Isaiah the same
book except you know we're reading an
English translation that I was looking
into this and I was hearing about that
Geneva Bible and the anglo-saxon I can't
pronounce it right and stuff like that
but I don't know if those were before or
after Jesus yeah good question the the
Geneva Bible and the anglo-saxon Bible
all the English translations they all
came after the time of Christ now of
course the time of Jesus there was no
New Testament that came after Christ
so the scrolls that Jesus used were the
Old Testament scrolls and they were
accepted by the religious leaders has
been inspired yet the books of Moses the
books of the prophets and that's what
Jesus quoted from and then you have the
Dead Sea Scrolls which date back to the
time of Christ and you can compare the
writing of the Dead Sea Scrolls with our
Bibles today and indeed it is very
accurate and it's the same same message
so yeah those probably were the scrolls
that Jesus used it would be the ones
relating of course when we say scrolls
we're not talking about a single scroll
the scrolls are copied and recopied and
we copied so there were copies of the
original but still very trustworthy and
accurate we have a gift book called the
ultimate resource on the Bible we'll be
happy to send you a free copy Chris oh
you'll have to do is call our resource
number it's eight hundred eight thirty
five six seven four seven and asked for
the book called
the ultimate resource that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven we have Henry listening in Bronx
New York Henry
to the program yes how are you pastures
my question is Adam and he they had two
sons right right yeah I think kilt evil
didn't he yes they say they found his
wife where did she come from yeah well
that's a good question we get it
frequently people start reading through
the Bible and by Chapter five they're
wondering where Cain got his wife
actually my chapter four do you see
there's Adam and Eve and then you know
Adam Eve f7 it says King took his wife
where'd she come from was there were
there other people Adam and Eve you read
in Chapter five of Genesis it says they
had sons and daughters there were many
children they lived hundreds of years
and they probably who knows they might
have had ten dozen kids every we don't
know what they had I was wondering what
number you were gonna pick yeah you know
there's I I think the world record for
one husband and wife that most children
is 69 children a Russian lady and her
husband had 69 children over the course
of her burying years must have been a
lot of twins they did they actually had
several sets of twins and one or two
sets of triplets yeah they were
following be fruitful and multiply there
was nothing wrong with marrying your
sister back then Adam and Eve actually
were both related to God when you think
about it the human genes were perfect it
wasn't until you get to the time of
Moses that they started saying brothers
should not be looking upon the nakedness
of his sister you weren't supposed to
marry close kin hope that helps a little
bit but Cain married probably one of his
sisters all right next caller that we
have is Caleb listening from Rockland
Washington
Caleb welcome to the program hi hi Caleb
and your question tonight
why was Daniel the only one who got
visions and Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego did not that's right Daniel had
three close friends when he was in
Babylon and they they stood up with him
when they decided not to eat the King's
food they also prayed with Daniel when
all the wise men were going to be
destroyed and God answered their prayers
and Daniel was given the vision God
gives different gifts to different
people some people can sing and some
people have the gift of being a pastor
or teacher an evangelist and Bible tells
us some people have the gift of dreams
or interpretation of dreams or prophecy
Daniel had the gift of prophecy Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego they were very
brave godly people they stood up even
though they went to a furnace but they
didn't have that gift God gives his
different gifts to different people not
all our prophets good question Caleb
thank you for calling be a faithful
Daniel yourself that's right next caller
that we have let's see we've got Leah
listening in Los Angeles Leah welcome to
the program we have just a few minutes
hi pastor all right good evening hi I do
have a question on the verses Isaiah 9
verse 6 to 7 um I was you know I saw
this Jewish rabbi claimed that the
grammatical tense that was used on the
Tanakh the hip the Bible was past tense
indicating that the event being referred
in the past but in our King James Bible
obviously it's using present tense
I'm confused faster I just need a
clarification of that thank you thank
you good question I appreciate that Leah
it actually says and this is a place
where it says for unto us a child is
born unto us a son is given and the
government will be or shall be upon his
shoulders well that's it reads that way
also even in the Hebrew Bible and his
name will be called future tense
wonderful counselor mighty God
everlasting father Prince of Peace of
the increase of his government and peace
there will be no end again still
speaking about the future upon the
throne of David and over his kingdom to
order and establish it with judgment and
justice from that time forward even
forevermore
well when Isaiah wrote this this Savior
who is going to sit on the throne of
David had not been
born yet I know that this verse and
other passages in Isaiah 53 makes some
of our Jewish brothers and sisters a
little uncomfortable because they seem
to be very powerful prophecies pointing
to Jesus as the Messiah that are hard to
deny and so it sounds like you know
they're trying to dismiss them by saying
oh well that was past tense but even in
the Hebrew Bible I've seen it it says
well it's using the future tense
language now I can't read Hebrew but
that's the English versions of the
Hebrew Bible that I've read Thank You
Lee I hope that helps a little bit hey
friends don't go anywhere we're just
taking a brief break and get a drink of
water and do some station identification
come back with more Bible questions you
can still call in with your questions in
just a few moments
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
com
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Corrine was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Corrine to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Corrine has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend have an
opportunity to help someone today and to
make an eternal difference for more
people like Corrine you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877 five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one or just visit give dot amazing facts
dot o-r-g or send your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight
thank you for studying the Word of God
with me today and I hope that you plan
now to join me again next week as we
discover more amazing facts
word of god every Bible question you
have answered moves you one step closer
to the fullness of God's will for your
life so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m.
Pacific time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 wearing our
Hawaiian shirts today and that's at the
Doug Batchelor Facebook site or the
amazing facts Facebook page my name is
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross and
we ready for our next caller we have cha
Kalia calling from New Jersey chuckling
yeah welcome to the program
it's ha ha Lea has an undercover you
know we were just discussing on the
break how exactly do we pronounce your
name so thanks for helping us with that
it's cover as in the Hebrew Adama color
which is Adam and Eve and where they got
the Eve from but Allah is the original
Hebrew and lay out who is the second
wife I paid for your check up
I know I've got a daughter named Roscoe
Leah so anyway your question okay
in Exodus when the ten commandments are
given we read honor thy father and thy
mother
however in Deuteronomy it's written
honor thy mother and my father why is
the difference in deuteronomy chapter 5
it says honor your father and mother but
you might be talking about leviticus
19:3 where it says honor your mother and
father
yah both should be honored are you just
saying why is there a switch in the
sequence yes you know I think that Moses
in Leviticus he flipped it around just
to show that especially when children
are young that they spend most of their
time with the mother in the home father
might be out working in the fields and
they are to be respecting their mothers
as they get a little older than their
boys might be spending more time with
their fathers and so I don't think it
changes the meaning do you I believe
there might be an interpretation as to
why there is a difference when what
would that be perhaps in the Talmud I
don't think there's a difference it says
honor your father another honor your
mother and your father that could be me
it's both honor your parents right and
then you go to in Colossians 3 where it
says everyone should honor their parents
and the Lord okay well I mean it's
cooler that we have then is Brian
listening in Spokane Brian welcome to
the program thank you gentlemen thank
you so much for your dedication to this
program and answering questions my
question today relates to kingdom
building and I'm just curious if there's
any reference in the Bible that that
indicates that heaven is currently
growing in size or that there's been
anybody that's been created or born in
heaven
just the creation of man that's a good
question I'm thinking as you're asking
the question you know there you have
some verses in Revelation that talk
about the creatures in heaven around the
throne of God
of course heaven will grow it's going to
be populated with the redeemed
I don't know pastor Ross do you think of
any verses that say that the heaven is
growing you know it almost seems as
though a creation was at one sense
almost the pause button was hit while
this rebellion came up with Satan and
that's been resolved what's in the
process of being resolved we know that
won't be babies being born in heaven at
least not from those who are resurrected
at the second coming Jesus says they
shall be as the Angels they neither
marry neither give any marriage so of
course the Angels don't procreate it's a
good question I mean the Bible does not
say specifically if God is still
currently creating but it seems as
though the focus at this point is what's
happening on earth and playing out the
great controversy yeah I think God has
pressed the pause button on new
creations until we get the the
redemption problem settled fair enough
thank you guys so much that's I was just
curious about that I mean in essence
we're we're Kingdom building but we that
won't happen until the second coming
yeah I don't think God has done creating
because the universe is infinite God is
infinite he loves to create and I think
as the endless eons roll by he will
continue to create more gotcha
thank you guys all right hey thanks so
much next caller that we have is a shear
listening from New Orleans Kashia
welcome to the program hello you're on
the air
hi thanks for calling I've been watching
you for over a year calling some on Dora
well bless your heart thank you so much
my son and I tonight 14 year old and he
questions ask the question today he
wants to know what happens like what
kind of clothes well I I don't think
he's gonna have to worry about being
bored I promise that the Bible says in
Psalm 16 at his right hand are pleasures
forevermore and so there will always be
something there that is going to be a
blessing and challenging his mind as far
as clothes we're gonna have garments I
think that are made out of light the
Lord is giving the people garments that
are washed white in the blood of the
Lamb and just like Adam and Eve had
these garments of light
before they sinned I think we're gonna
have these robes of righteousness don't
think we're gonna have robes that are
made out of fig leaves or cotton or skin
and there will be endless opportunities
to do things it says that children will
play with the animals in heaven bible
does talk about says the New Jerusalem
children playing in the streets of it
and will mount up with wings like eagles
will run and not be weary will walk and
not faint seems to imply we can fly so
the idea being bored perish the thought
there'll be endless opportunities and
activities for heaven Bible talks about
building houses in the earth and
planting gardens and eating the fruit
thereof so matter of fact we have a
study guide called colossal city in
space that talks a little bit about
heaven at least the New Jerusalem and if
you haven't seen this
Deshea I think you'd enjoy it you can
share it with your family the number is
883 five six seven four seven if you're
in North America if you're not in North
America all you'll need to do is go to
the amazing facts or website amazing
facts RG you'll be able to read that
study guide on heaven for free next
caller that we have is Jenny listening
from Detroit Michigan Jenny welcome to
the program thank you yeah your question
thank you for taking my question my
question has to do with what what does
the Bible say about what house espouse
responds when they're in a abusive
marriage I'm not physically abusive but
emotionally and verbally abusive well
that's that is a difficult question but
first let me tell you I wrote a book
that will send you a free copy and it's
called marriage divorce and remarriage
and I don't know if you're asking about
yourself or on behalf of a friend the
Bible criteria for grounds for divorce
now I'm talking about separation but
divorce is if the marriage vows have
been broken by infidelity you need to be
very careful when we start saying abuse
we're talking about emotional abuse
because it is so hard to draw
the line on the you know some I have
seen some couples where there was
tremendous emotional abuse from the
husband and the wife just I sure
wouldn't want to live with it it was
pretty bad just one person is constantly
being put down and degraded and
humiliated and no physical abuse but
terrible emotional abuse and
manipulation and just unbearable
circumstances you know sometimes you may
have to separate until the other party
agrees to counseling and you may have to
permanently separate but as far as
divorce
usually people divorce because then they
look forward to getting remarried at
some point you've got to be very careful
everyone starts calling everything abuse
and every argument becomes abuse you got
to be careful that sometimes the
terminology is not abuse and yet there
are very real cases of serious
mistreatment in marriage situations and
that need counseling it's easier if both
parties are Christian and they'll agree
to it makes it difficult if one is a
believer and the other is not and they
don't agree to counseling sometimes you
need to take some drastic steps again I
think that book that you have pastor
Doug deals with the subject and I think
it'll be helpful for anyone wanting to
learn more about what does the Bible say
about marriage it's called marriage
divorce remarriage we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and just asked for the book on marriage
and we'll send it after you
we have Robert - he's listening Robert
welcome to the program hi Pastor Ross
hello pastor Doug hi thanks for calling
yes my question was regarding 1st
Corinthians 15 verse 22 it says for as
in Adam all die even so in Christ also
be made alive some people that I have
talked to believe that because of the
resurrection everyone gets to live
forever kind of thing because of this
verse write this because it says in
Christ all shall be made alive well
technically everyone is resurrected by
the power of Christ the wicked are
raised for judgment Daniel says many of
those who sleep in the dust of the earth
this is Daniel 12 will come forth they
that have done good
the resurrection of life they that have
done evil the resignation mixing two
verses and mixing John 10 and Daniel 12
Daniel talks about the resurrection of
condemnation Jesus says there is a
resurrection of life and a resurrection
of damnation so you've got both
resurrections that they're being brought
forth by the power of Christ that
doesn't mean that they're being brought
forth to be given eternal life they're
being brought forth for the great white
throne judgment see what I'm saying
uh-huh
so if people use this first and they say
well we're all being resurrected by
Christ that means everyone's being saved
this verse doesn't say that just in the
same way that through into that people
are being resurrected by Christ's power
by his power not by Satan yeah Satan has
no power to give life when Christ is
gonna call forth the dead for for their
judgment though after the 1000 years the
rest of the Dead who are the wicked are
raised and in the same way it says for
an atom all die well does that mean in
Adam all are lost no he's talking about
all the sons of Adam all humans died
because of the sin of Adam some died
saved some died lost so you have to
compare this scripture with other
scriptures that are very clear that
there's two kinds of people that are
dead now the saved in the loss the dead
in Christ and the others yes that makes
completely sense
that makes complete sense yeah no we do
have a study guide that talks about the
resurrection of death yes talking about
the second coming of Christ we'll be
able to send it to anyone who calls and
asks matter of fact we have one even
more specific called are the dead really
dead dealing with the subject of death
the number again is 808 three five six
seven four seven and as for the study
guide are the dead really did
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture Egyptians built pyramids to help
guide the spirits of their leaders Rome
sanctioned holidays to honor and appease
the spirits of their dead even the Bible
tells of a king that used a witch to
contact the spirit of a deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter we invite you to look inside and
find out for yourself visit death truth
dot-com for life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm or
call one eight hundred five three eight
seven two seven five
we have payme listening in Michigan
Penney welcome to the program hello how
are you guys good thank you for calling
thank you for taking my call I'm really
nervous here oh don't be what I'm
calling about is is baptism
if you've already gave your life to God
and you're safe is it necessary that you
have to be baptized
why would you not want to be baptized
penny it's just a question because I've
always been taught that once you were
saved through the blood of Jesus Christ
that was the only thing to go to heaven
yeah let me read a couple verses to you
Jesus says in mark chapter 16 that
they're to go into all the world preach
the gospel whoever believes and is
baptized will be saved in Matthew 28
Jesus said go and preach the gospel
baptized in the name of the Father Son
and Holy Spirit
Paul was told by Ananias arise and be
baptized and wash away your sins baptism
the ceremony there's only two
institutions that Jesus gave to the
Christian Church you've got the Lord's
Supper communion service and your
baptism and baptism is as important to a
Christian as a wedding ceremony is to a
marriage it marks the beginning of your
commitment it represents washing away
from sin that you're making a covenant
with God to give your life to Him and
accept his forgiveness so it's very
important but I wouldn't want anyone to
rush into it I mean don't you don't have
to rush off and grab a pastor and say
can you baptize me tomorrow because I
want to make sure I'm saved I would
study it if I were you so when you do
get baptized you get the most blessing
out of it you possum
we can well the reason I'm sorry to
interrupt but the reasons work for me
asking that is my mother passed in the
hospital she was saying she lived her
life she lives her life for God she was
saying she's very ill and she begged to
be baptized and they wouldn't baptize
her until she had a full body yeah you
know anything till she could be immersed
yeah oh don't tell your tell your family
not to worry because the thief on the
cross who accepted Jesus he could not
get baptized in Christ said you're gonna
be in heaven if your mother's heart was
that she was willing to but because of
her medical condition she couldn't she's
gonna get credit for Jesus baptism
because Jesus was not baptized for his
sin he was baptized as an example and on
behalf of those who can't be you go to a
prison and you someone comes to the Lord
may be on death row or in the last hours
of their life and prison may not
accommodate a baptism well as baptism
gonna be an obstacle to that person
salvation no it is a ceremony it's
symbolic now it's very important if you
can be that you should be but if you
can't Christ is not gonna exclude
someone from heaven because they've
accepted him and they can't be baptized
so does that make sense
it sure does hey you still would enjoy
the study on the subject would be happy
to send you a free copy and again
the study guide is cold well I'm
thinking of the book called baptism is
it really necessary that a little bit
more with that specific question the
number again is 883 five six seven four
seven as for the book called baptism is
it really necessary
we've got Rick listening from New Jersey
Rick welcome to the program I said
pastor Ross I've listed there Christian
radio stations through my life well for
a long time I think you guys do a great
job that one caller I didn't understand
where he was coming from but you guys
handled it well I was so surprised by
that oh yeah well most of our customers
are pretty happy but every now and then
you know I just rest my head yeah anyway
but what I listened
I was reading today about first saw fell
from grace and it says that what an evil
spirit came upon him he would have David
played a Harper the leader to soothe the
spirit right I was wondering was I know
would that be the first case of demon
possession mentioned in the Old
Testament because because I don't think
demon possessions really mentioned soul
Jesus taught but it was that just maybe
a psychological thing with him or you
think it really was maybe a reference to
demon possession for Saul I think that
Saul was demon possessed or at least
demon harassed when he grieved away the
spirit that's when you know it says that
Lord sent us a spirit to trouble him
basically as Saul rejected the light of
God all that's left is darkness and and
when David would come and David would
just introduce that that positive spirit
and that light both through his word and
music and it would chase away the
demonic influence but you know probably
came if you go back a little further in
the Bible Cain was probably at least
temporarily possessed by the devil when
he killed his brother out of a fit of
anger so you know there probably other
cases you could point to in the Old
Testament where it certainly wasn't the
Lord leading some of the characters and
their bad behavior no that's a good
question I I do think that Saul was
demon-possessed ultimately he went to a
witch fell on his own sword kind of like
Judas hung himself and the hippo fell
hung themselves those that kind of
reject the Lord often self-destruct of
course to weaken repeatedly trying to
kill a David's jealousy
yeah maybe they're jobs that was trying
to talk him out of it
yeah Saul was really possessed by pride
too because he'd some wanted so much for
his dynasty to continue that he he tried
to thwart the purpose of God and picking
David hey we thank you very much Rick
for your call hoping a good question
hope that helps a little thank you next
caller that we have is Emanuel listening
from Massachusetts Emanuel
program ie their ambassador good how can
we help you tonight
yeah my question is is it a sin to
listen to secular music alright just for
friends that are listening you've got
two kinds of general music that a
Christian would categorize things and
you've got your sacred music which is
Christian music it's got biblical themes
and theology and then you have secular
music which is going to be music that is
not necessarily sacred not all secular
music is bad you might you have to look
at the individual songs you could be
singing in a patriotic song you know
just this land is your land this land is
my land a folk song you have to look at
the words and certain types of music you
know if you sing a lullaby you sing mary
had a little lamb while you put your
baby to sleep it's certainly not sinful
it's a secular song I throw some argue
the Mary in the story is Mary the mother
of Jesus but how you know Michael row
your boat ashore then again some people
argue that Michael is gay
it's Jesus so you know this what am I
looking for a twinkle twinkle there you
go 20 Cal 20 little who what parent out
there has not heard their kid played
twinkle twinkle when they were learning
piano or violin or something that's a
secular song but there's nothing wrong
with it but there is secular music that
in the words so the music is very
raucous and it's you know there's sacred
music and there's kind of diabolical
music sounds and words you can have
beautiful music that's got evil words
Frank Sinatra used to sing a song I did
it my way the devil could sing that song
beautiful melody but the message wasn't
really good and then I've heard people
try and put good words the diabolical
music and that never works
I hope this is making sense but you know
Emanuel I've got a CD you can listen to
online for free it's actually a youtube
it's on the Christian and music and if
you just type in Doug Batchelor in that
title on YouTube I think it'll take you
there okay goes into a lot more detail
but music now we get a book don't we
we've got there a book talks about a few
notes on music by Louie Torres it's a
small book it talks well I think we
might have something on music
yeah well we need to look at that on the
website bastard eh wait you know what
you can you could take a run at it
Emmanuel just call amazing facts and say
can I have your sermon booked on music I
wonder what they'd send you or you can
look at the youtubes online but it's a
deep subject you know we do have a book
called culture and the Christian oh
there you go that might touch on some of
that and I think that's addressed in
there as well again the number is 883
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the book called culture and the
Christian and again we'll send it out to
anyone who calls and asks let's see we
got Marc listening from Michigan Marc
welcome to the program we have just a
few minutes oh good evening yes my
question I know the ten commandments are
eternal sacrificial laws no longer are
performed because they were fulfilled in
Jesus but what about some other laws in
Leviticus in 12 six talks about after
birthing mothers unclean for two weeks
in 1516 talk about bodily fluids unclean
for a time and in chapter 19 talks about
don't Mar the corners of your beard and
21 it talks about not making baldness on
your head now I'm trying to figure out
what are the principles behind that
which laws do you keep and which yeah
how do you yeah how do you discern well
right first of all let me touch on
quickly on the ones that you've just
mentioned there are several categories
of law you've got summer health law some
are ceremonial law some are civil laws
God also had like some moral laws he
said do not Mar the corners of your
beard you read later in Leviticus he
says do not cut the corners of your
beard for the dead and he talks about
making yourself bald for the dead
because the pagans had a custom to show
you were mourning they would cut
themselves they'd cut off their beards
and God says look don't do anything like
that to yourself for the dead so that
was really something that still applies
today you know God doesn't want us
mutilating ourselves or our appearance
when were in mourning Christians have a
blessed hope and we're not supposed to
act like the pagans do as far as the
laws of purification for a woman giving
birth those I think fell under the
category of spiritual law is connected
with the sanctuary obviously a woman
doesn't have to wait 8 weeks when she
goes to church we don't have a temple
anymore so coming you know to worship
the Lord of
back in Bible times they figured any
bodily issue was a symbol of sin and you
were not to come into the presence of
the sacred confines of the sanctuary in
that condition I think those laws are
ceremonial laws that have been nailed to
the cross they have spiritual meaning
and I think you mentioned one other I
don't remember but some of them were
civil laws yeah you just kind of go
through them and Moses lumps them all
together I think some of it related
neurology ceremonial but also the health
and you have some health principles as
well that Moses speaks of and there's
good health principles behind it maybe
the application is a little different
today but the principle is good I mean
you've got to wash your hands if you're
gonna be preparing food and I mean
there's some practical principles there
if you found a dead mouse inside a clay
pot you were to break it but if it was a
metal pot you could wash it and that's
this a practical sanitation it would the
porous clay it would permeate hey I hope
that helps a little bit
mark we are out of time listening
friends we're gonna have some important
closing announcements we always hope
that you hang on for the caboose and
hear what's going on with the ministry
but we just want to remind you how much
we appreciate your tuning in the only
way amazing facts is able to do this we
have no corporation or denomination that
underwrites this it's people like you if
you've been blessed by these programs
and want to keep it on your station
click amazing facts and then click
donate god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
did you know that Noah was present to
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com what if you could know the
future what would you do what would you
change to see the future you must
understand the past Alexander the Great
becomes king when he's only 18 but he's
a military prodigy a hundred and fifty
years in advance Cyrus had been named
wrong was violent they were ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
see his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com de Gino
amazing facts has a free Bible school
that you can do from the comfort of your
own home it includes 27 beautifully
illustrated study lessons to aid in your
study of God's Word sign up today for
this free Bible study course by calling
1-800 four two one five 7,000 that's one
eight four four two one five 7,000
[Music]
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
comm if you'd like to enhance your study
of God's Word
visit our website at
www.lazyguycooking.com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]